your dog's name is Blue Ginger she's
actually a trained sous chef and she has
a mini apron she hangs out with me in
the kitchen
all right welcome to Next Level kitchen
where we're elevating your cooking
skills to the next level by teaching you
the skills and tricks to make some Next
Level dishes absolutely and I know some
of you are wondering what to do with
leftover wine at home but we've got you
covered with pasta there it is and some
of you are like what do you mean
leftover wine I never have wine left
over well the perfect vessel for your
wine leftovers is pasta but before we
get cooking let's get to level one
you're cooking in white one yes okay
what are you using today I'm using red
wine oh my goodness so you like cooking
with white wine
um in this application yes I also enjoy
cooking with red wine same I like
cooking with both I love that red Wine's
a simple sauce right yes so red wine
sugar and onion in a pan yes 20 minutes
later is a nice sauce for a steak maybe
right or a little bit to deglaze a pan
if you're braising some meat some short
ribs beef anything like that Bolognese a
bowling absolutely right and white wine
yeah I mean for me I think white wine
lends itself really well to like lighter
Meats like fish chicken and clams which
I see you're about to cook exactly one
of my favorite ingredients listen I'm
from Long Island New York where clams
are king I feel like yes there's so much
flavor in clams but you're going to tell
us all about that absolutely I'm gonna
start mine over here at night I'm gonna
cook with red wine and I saw this on
social media I'm so excited about that
and I'm not embarrassed to be like I saw
this on social media and I'm gonna give
it a try I'm going to
cook my pasta
in red wine but it's a whole bottle of
red wine and like this this doesn't have
to be super expensive fancy red wine uh
but again this is shocking to me I would
never do this as a classically trained
Chef okay but I'm just gonna heat up my
wine and I'm gonna use bucatini which is
awesome
sort of thick noodle right here and I'm
gonna let that cook in my my red wine
until the red wine evaporates and the
pasta is done wow I'm so excited to see
how this turns out I'm sure it's going
to be amazing I'm gonna start slicing my
aromatics here I have some shallot I
also have some Fresno chilies
and I have some garlic
voila what you got amazing yeah so I'm
again my my pasta has to cooked and as
the uh as the red wine heats up here I'm
just making sure that I get all of my
noodles uh submerged in that red wine
because you know when you first add your
your spaghetti or in this case the
bucatini to the water you know the ends
of it don't aren't quite submerged so
I'm just gonna make sure that I get that
cooked down in the red wine and just
like you I'm gonna start all of my other
ingredients so that when the pasta is
done I can just do a quick little pan
sauce oh I love that pasta is all about
like Alma nude finishes isn't it
absolutely and my I'm using actually a
linguine today so mine will take a
little bit less time I'm gonna start to
drop my pasta and so by the time my
aromatics are cooked and my clams take
no time the pasta will be ready to go
all right so I'm chopping up some uh a
little bit of red jalapenos over here
and mine's gonna be simple it's going to
be Chili's garlic and a little bit of
pancetta I'm gonna chop up this pancetta
basically Italian bacon Rosemary black
pepper her but if you don't have
pancetta you can use bacon or quite
honestly any salty pork product that you
have at home
all right so I got that chopping up I
have my pancetta I'm waiting for my
pasta to cook down we're looking at us
getting our mise en Place organized over
here look at us uh getting chilies again
all of these flavors spice I'm getting
salt from the uh pancetta you're getting
salt from clams I'm getting salt from
the ocean thanks ocean I love the ocean
yes and so uh with this I'm not worrying
about my knife Cuts I'm not worried
about slicing a perfect beautiful brunwa
no I just want a nice easy little clam
dish to use up the leftover white wine
that I have from my dinner yesterday all
right so you're getting your pan sauce
going yep and there we go I'm getting
I'm making sure that this bucatini gets
down into the sauce and Cooks away down
there and so with the garlic I'm just
gonna do a little crush I don't want to
chop chop it too much I want I really
want that rust thickness in this right
and with the clams so quick the most
beautiful part about clams is cooking
them quickly you do not want them to
become tough so you want a nice hot
smoking pan and it's really just a toss
and it's it takes no time at all and
again when you're cooking with clams or
over here I'm cooking with a pancetta as
a cook yes remembering that they're
salty absolutely I'm gonna also finish
with some Parmesan cheese over here
another salty ingredient love that so
just being mindful that we're not over
seasoning things makes sense okay Chef
so I'm going with in with aromatics
straight away you want that ASMR right
you want that Sizzle right and it's a
dump
right you want that to heat up and then
in goes the white wine
easy peasy done done done
so those are gonna Steam and my pasta is
going to go in right directly into this
pan one of the most important elements
is thinking about the carryover cook
right because I really want this pasta
to soak up that delicious and natural
juice that these clams are going to get
off so I don't want to cook my pasta all
the way through I want to cook it just
to Al Dente all right so you got the
clam steaming over there yes I have a
little bit of olive oil but not a lot
I'm going to add all of my pancetta that
pancetta is going to render but look at
this after you know minutes of cooking
looks right there now again cooked in
the red one you can smell the red one
good thing here is yeah please that the
red wine the alcohol is cooked out right
so if you're if you're thinking about
eating this at home like the alcohol as
it reduces it Cooks away wow
um so what do you think incredible
incredible I'm taking notes Chef okay
well man it's the first time I'm doing
it so I'm taking notes as well I got my
pancetta rendering I want that to get
nice and crispy you had mentioned it
when you were over there uh chopping
something you were like you know Italian
food it doesn't have to be so what I
love about it is that it's so fluid yes
and it doesn't have to be like brunoise
it can just be like rough chop right
there's just such a great fluidity to
Italian cuisine 100 I can't wait to get
to Italy because I think it's
think it's one of the beautiful things
about the Italian cuisine is it's really
about a celebration of like really
amazing ingredients absolutely done well
so there we go my pancetta cooked out
getting nice and crispy uh now I'm gonna
go ahead and add uh the rest of my
ingredients in here your pasta is
cooking away yep again I want to get
these nice and crispy here now I'll add
some of my chilies
all right so again salty pork spicy
chilies oh my gosh a little bit of
garlic is going to come in here as well
I'm just gonna toss in a little bit of
butter a little bit I'm gonna go too
classic no I love that but yeah and like
listen I noticed also you're gonna get
to it right but like I noticed that
there is a big chunk of Parmesan over
here yes there is with clams yes I know
it's like it's my take on a pasta what
are your thoughts on cheese with clams
listen I again as a native New Yorker
even though my there's no Italian in My
DNA yeah uh you've heard the saying that
you don't use cheese with with seafood
and I totally disagree I could not
disagree more actually if it tastes good
it tastes dude that's what I'm saying
like some rules are meant to be broken I
also feel like if you know the rules you
can like break them you know that's true
it just has to taste delicious it's a
bad experience okay all right there we
go that smells amazing over here I'm
gonna add my pasta and it's Al Dente
same you got your pasta I'm gonna add my
pasta over here as well look how
beautiful this looks I'm actually
so shocked like I might I might actually
do this in one of my restaurants oh it's
so pretty listen I have my pancetta my
chili my garlic yes and then the pasta
as you're doing as I'm doing it comes
straight from the pan that it was cooked
in right to the sauce wow do not rinse
your pasta under cold water like my mom
would do Peggy did not know exactly how
to cook authentic Italian food and again
if you rinse your pasta the sauce
doesn't stick to it right that's why
we're not running any water under it
there it is a little bit of pepper
little bit of salt
I think I'm almost ready to Plate how
are you doing yeah almost ready to play
it just want these flavors to sort of
marry up together
finish with a little bit of fresh
parsley
I love that I love that I think we
should open up a pasta recipe Chef I'm
not mad at it I mean this is nice fresh
olive oil oh it's so pretty
I'm not gonna get crazy with the
presentation I'm just gonna go sort it
right to the plate
get all of that on there
with all of that flavor and then
whatever's left in the pan like get all
those little bits the chilies the
pancetta
little little drizzle of olive oil
around it
listen one of the things I love about
presenting uh pasta dish is like just
let it go to the plate totally like you
can swirl it you can do all of those
things but like it's meant to go from
the pan to the plate totally really
really simple let it fall I always tell
my chefs let it fall like it fell from
the sky oh I love that that perfectly
imperfect look now of course the
parachuted very gently exactly where I
wanted it to go as a chef but let it
fall and then a little bit of this
shaved Parmesan which is nice and sweet
and salty
can never have too much
um I want to drink that broth over there
yes a little cheese the piece they
resisted there it is there it is okay
bring it over here you got the cheese
I'll give mine a little cheese too
double cheese
ah then it melts in and kind of makes a
rich sauce
well I love that nice and salty linguine
and clams with white wine sauce just for
you it's your favorite dish
bucatini cooked in red wine this is what
to do with your leftover wine
now that's how you make a Next Level
dish to get ingredients and more details
on the recipes from today check the
description below and be sure to
subscribe for more episodes of Next
Level kitchen
[Music]
foreign